paul
[Musique]
le budget primitif 2020 du département
d'un montant de 1 milliard 97 millions
d'euros a été voté à l'unanimité ce
mercredi 12 février en séance plénière
la recentralisation du rsa acté au 1er
janvier a permis à la collectivité de
dégager 60 millions d'euros
des marges de manoeuvre qui vont
permettre au département d'intervenir de
manière plus soutenue dans divers
secteurs
c'est 60 millions de plus vont nous
permettre de retrouver une capacité
d'intervention notamment dans le champ
de l'action sociale
en clair c'est à dire quoi d'abord en
faveur des politiques
la petite enfance l'enfance en
difficulté les collégiens les parents
mais aussi les grands parents les
personnes âgées et personnes en
situation de handicap
nous allons apporter plus d'être en
faveur de nos publics en difficulté plus
d'amélioration de l'habitat
en clair par exemple le nombre de
logements qu'on va réhabiliter et bien
va passer à 2 milles sur tout le
territoire de la réunion
nous allons mettre plus de crédit aussi
en faveur de la culture puis ce que le
sport qui permettent la promotion des
femmes et des hommes réunionnais la
politique de l'enfance j'y tiens parce
que le jeune ben souffre parfois de
difficultés dans la vie il ya le
problème des addictions
nous allons mettre des moyens pour
lutter contre les addictions alcool
drogue tabac etc
tout ça ce sont des moyens
supplémentaires et je dirais que en
faveur aussi des parents quand nous
réinvestissons pour leurs jeunes
on accompagne les parents à travers les
pmi politique d'action sociale et volet
lutte contre les grossesses précoces
tous ses champs on va les retrouver
vivants les réinvestir pour moi ce que
je souhaite c'est que les familles en
difficulté de la réunion bénéficie de
l'aide du département
là où elle se trouve et que chacun
puisse bénéficier de ses droits
même les familles les plus reculés dans
les coins les plus éloignés de la
réunion le département des finances donc
plus
rsa mais souhaite accompagner ses
bénéficiaires à travers un nouveau
dispositif
nous allons mettre en place un plan une
expérimentation qui vise à faire en
sorte que 5000 personnes bénéficiaient
du rsa puissent retrouver une activité
pérenne
nous sommes en train de finaliser notre
dossier il sera prêt ici on va dire vers
le mois de juin et nous allons lancer
cette expérimentation qui vise à pois
tout simplement celles et ceux qui
veulent créer leur propre activité leur
propre entreprise
on va les accompagner celles et ceux qui
veulent aller travailler dans les mondes
agricoles dans les entreprises qui ont
du mal à trouver un emploi
on va mieux les accompagner on va mieux
accompagner aussi celles et ceux qui
veulent profiter de la mobilité
professionnelle
donc tout cela ce sont des chants
d'accompagnement le but pour nous c'est
que pendant la période d'un ciation que
le bénéficiaire du rsa carotte le
bénéfice de son rsa un vote du budget
historique selon le président du
département délesté du poids du rsa la
collectivité a également doublé son taux
dépargne brute qui atteint désormais 81
5 millions d'euros
[Musique]